[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily a
vaccination fraud scheme to the tune of
1.5 million dollars how two long island
nurses were caught in a coveted
crackdown plus opening statements are
presented in ohio as a woman stands
trial for the murder of her boyfriend
but was it self-defense and the tragic
death of lauren smith fields why her
family says law enforcement botched the
investigation they are citizens of this
country
and their daughter died and they've been
treated like second-class citizens but
first he asked some of the patrons to
keep me breathing they asked me to say
jesus
because i guess they knew our faith and
they were like if you can say that you
know it'll keep you alive
and it did poignant testimony delivered
in the trial of the accused waffle house
shooter law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian vockmeyer along with terry
austin emotional testimony is presented
in the trial of the accused waffle house
shooter
videos were so graphic the testimony so
compelling jurors were seen crying and
passing around boxes of tissues that's
because back in 2018 prosecutors say
travis ranking walked into a waffle
house in nashville tennessee and opened
fire killing four people and injuring
others after a 34-hour manhunt involving
almost every three-letter agency rankin
was taken into custody the trial was put
on hold for months as ranking was
treated for schizophrenia a judge later
deemed him fit to stand trial ranking
has pled not guilty to 16 charges
including four counts of murder he faces
life in prison
after monday's opening statements jurors
heard heart-wrenching testimony from
survivors of the shooting including
james shaw jr the name may be familiar
because shaw was hailed as a hero for
rushing ranking and grabbing the barrel
of his gun and on monday he told jurors
what led up to the shooting
did you see anyone inside of that truck
yes i did
you're kind of looking over to your left
i'm are you seeing the person that you
saw inside the truck in this courtroom
he's giving me the same look he did that
night and what was that look
looked like he didn't care
did uh either of you say anything
mention that look the way that he was
looking your mr mcmurray so brennan gave
you the pg-13 version brendan said to me
look at this crazy
go shoot up the place was there ever a
pause
in the gunshots
yes it was
what
what did you do when you heard the pause
i acted
what do you mean by that
um there was a voice that told me to do
it
do it now
and i acted upon that voice
um
because i didn't see any other way
that's why i didn't go in the bathroom
because i thought myself that's like
shooting
shooting fishing up in a barrel
literally um so i wanted to stay outside
that door
um
try to keep eye on him and just try to
find my moment just try to find my
opportunity
and it presented itself
and what did you do when you when you
found your moment
i ran through the door as fast as i
could
um
in such a short corridor
um it's really only two steps that i
took behind the door and i just ran
through the door thinking
is either going to be me or him or it's
going to be you know
deaf
we'll see what happens i had to think
while we were literally fighting
i had to think of
what i could do
and not get injured at the same time
and get away
so giving up my hand was the only thing
i could do
you're gonna have to grab the barrel
james you don't have to push it down
jurors also heard from another shooting
victim who's had 24 surgeries because of
the mass shooting
as soon as he came in the door
he looked me in my eyes
and he shot me immediately
he shot me three times my leg was
detached
it was hanging on by like tendons and
skin
and i remember
looking at it and because i didn't see
my arm at first and i just remember
looking at my leg like god please help
me because i i don't think
i'm gonna make it
and i looked at my leg and i
passed out
cause i think i was in such shock
um that i passed out for a couple of
seconds
and do you remember feeling pain at that
moment
immediately
can you describe that pain
it was the worst pain i've ever felt
on tuesday testimony began with another
eyewitness who appears to address the
defendant with a look of disgust
you said that you had injuries from
glass where were the injuries from the
glass
the injuries from the glass were on my
face
like i said it was just
minor little scratches and lacerations
that was physical the mental
damage damages forever
joining us today is civil rights
attorney philip hamilton and terry
austin philip shaw jr thought ranking
looked like a shooter even before it all
happened
and said the same thing about him in the
courtroom now does that help the defense
in pleading insanity
if you're the defense attorney you're
always going to try to turn the facts in
your favor so to the extent that he has
that cold soulless look that we just saw
on camera and to the extent that that's
the look that shaw is saying he saw on
scene as a defense attorney of course
brian you're gonna play that up however
there's a flip side to that the danger
in that is that he looks like he doesn't
care he looks like someone who's not
going to get much sympathy from a jury
with these facts and these witnesses so
to the extent that your defense you're
going to try to use it but certainly
it's just as damaging on the other side
yeah let's kind of look at that other
side terry how do you think charlotte
junior's testimony went because it seems
even the jury got emotional uh and
really felt his pain as he testified
brian i thought both the direct and the
cross examination went extremely well he
told everything that happened in his own
words it was very emotional and when he
was asked how do you think you did it
how did you help these people he
actually said i was favored and i was
blessed and when he said that he started
to tear up and i'm sure the jury did as
well as far as i'm concerned he is a
true hero
more people could have absolutely gotten
injured or killed the only issue on the
cross was whether or not there was a
racially insensitive word but i think
that's irrelevant yeah favored and
blessed definitely strong words from a
strong witness there make sure to check
out the law and crime network for gavin
to gavel coverage of this tennessee
verse travis ranking still ahead of law
and crime daily we head to ohio as a
woman stands trout for the murder of her
daughter's father but first the tragic
death of lauren smithfield our own terri
austin speaks with a family attorney who
says they were major gaps in the death
investigation
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back two connecticut officers
are placed on lead as official announced
the death of lauren smithfield will now
be investigated as a crime co-host terry
austin joins us now to break down the
case so far terry
brian the death of lauren smith feels
has recently gained traction after
critics say it did not initially receive
the attention it deserved friends and
family also say investigators were
racially insensitive when handling the
case
the 23 year old black woman died on
december 12th last year in what's being
ruled an accidental overdose
bridgeport connecticut officials report
alcohol
hydroxazine promethazine and fentanyl
were found in her system
police responded to a 9-1-1 call from
37-year-old matthew lafontaine a white
man he told officials he met smithfields
only three days prior via the dating app
bumble lafontaine has not been charged
in the case members of her family say
investigators violated their civil
rights by failing to notify them of her
death and by mishandling the death
investigation
i spoke with the family attorney who
tells me bridgeport connecticut
officials did not do the investigation
justice
the police got involved and instead of
quarantining off the area instead of
collecting anything of material value
they said this gentleman is a nice guy
he called 9-1-1 there's nothing to see
here and he's not even a person of
interest they let him go and they never
did anything else it's not just a cliche
when you say person of interest it's a
real thing what that means is if
someone's dead
um there's blood there's a bloody bed
sheet here
we are interested as law enforcement to
find out what happened
in this particular case it seems like
they just weren't interested
and they just let them go
and all of the experts that i've talked
to said that the way you approach these
cases is to treat it like a homicide and
if you have to dial it down you dial it
down but it's not going to work if you
just let the guy go don't preserve the
scene and you don't do all the proper
proper steps and then try to dial it up
it doesn't work that way
crossland tells me the family has
announced a 30 million dollar lawsuit
against the city of bridgeport in
punitive damages the city's mayor also
announced the office of internal affairs
will conduct an independent
investigation of the police
investigation brian
thanks terry let's bring back civil
rights attorney philip hamilton and
terry austin as we dive into the death
and bosch investigation of lauren smith
fields terry so where do we go now that
the criminal investigation into
smithfield's death
now we see what two officers are
suspended what's next
you know brian the family wants answers
they want to know whether or not this
was a murder or whether or not this was
an accidental overdose so they want
authorities to test all of the evidence
the fingerprints the dna and anything
else that might be incriminating and
they want the authorities to speak to
witnesses they want light shed on
exactly what happened because at this
point they have no idea and if in fact
they do find that this individual was
responsible they want charges to be
brought and the attorney is absolutely
trying and hoping to keep the case in
the media all right so philip we saw
there that uh there is a civil rights
lawsuit but what is the biggest flaw
that you've heard so far in the
investigation that can lead to a strong
civil rights claim
you know brian i don't know when we talk
about the civil rights side of things if
there's anything that makes the claim
strong only because law enforcement is
always afforded so much protection by
means of qualified immunity and
certainly we've talked about this a lot
even with criminal cases that have been
covered on this network that being said
there has been case law and precedent
dating back to the 80s that does allow
private citizens to sue law force law
enforcement agencies for negligence say
with certain crimes involving domestic
violence etc when investigations are not
done properly could they ultimately move
on that in or on other ends yes does it
make the lawsuit strong not necessarily
this is more of a political angle that
the attorney wants to take in terms of
keeping pressure on the department
because ultimately somebody's going to
be held accountable even if not in a
civil court of law all right we'll see
how this plays out we've got an
investigation as this is now considered
a crime we've got a civil rights lawsuit
going we'll make sure to keep tabs on
this case as it develops coming up on
law and crime daily two long island
nurses face forgery charges after
selling fake coven 19 vaccination cards
plus opening statements are presented in
ohio versus audrey cole hear from both
sides after this
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
we're following a murder trial out of
ohio of audrey cole a veteran who's
accused of shooting and killing her
boyfriend who was also a vet in their
home last year on tuesday several law
enforcement officers took the stand
testifying about processing the scene
after the shooting
cold is accused of shooting and killing
her boyfriend matthew mott inside their
carroll county home on may 3 2021.
cole's defense team argues mott was
physically abusing and beating cole when
he slammed her head through a wall
before the shooting occurred on tuesday
investigators testified about that hole
in the bedroom wall the single empty
bullet casing found in the bathroom and
another unspent casing found in the
hallway in opening statements cole's
defense attorneys told the jury she
acted in self-defense when she shot him
with an ar-15 in the hallway of their
home prosecutors say after the shot was
fired mott went out into the front yard
where he died in the defense's opening
statement monday attorney chase mallory
described what they believe happened
before mott was shot
so she goes up to the bedroom to remove
herself from the situation let's not
escalate this anymore separates herself
from the situation audrey sits on her
bed by herself
looking at her phone
she's sitting on the edge of her bed
looking at her phone finding her own
business
when matt comes up the stairs
unwilling to put this argument aside
when he just loses his temper completely
he loses all control of his emotions
she's sitting here on the edge of her
bed
he reaches over he grabs her by
she takes a step or two out of her
into the hall and that's when matt comes
around the corner
comes around the corner she sees him he
sees her and he comes at her again just
the way he did moments before when he
brutally beat her and caused her serious
physical harm
the prosecution told the jury in their
opening the two veterans may have fought
but this case isn't about self-defense
this case is about a defendant who
brought a gun to a fist fight and
finished that fight by shooting the
father of her child
with one shot
one kill
this case is not a whodunit
okay
identity is not an issue when people
live together they may have unhealthy
relationships they may not be able to
live with each other and they may not be
able to live without each other
but at the end of the day
an unarmed man was shot
their fight was over
there was no reason
to pull that trigger
civil rights attorney philip hamilton
and co-host terry austin are back to
break down opening statements in ohio
the audrey cole terry how did the
prosecution push back on the argument of
self defense we kind of saw it there but
was it effective
i thought that the prosecution's
argument was very effective brian listen
the jury can relate to anyone who has a
marital argument because people argue
all the time and it doesn't need to end
up with someone being killed so they're
going to have to determine whether or
not this force was reasonable and i
think the burden of proof for the
prosecution might be hard the
prosecution is going to have to make
sure that each and every one of those
jurors thinks
beyond a reasonable doubt that you know
this was not necessary yeah philip i'm
guessing the defense attorney would say
something a little different but you
being a former public defender how do
you think the defense's opening was
in saying that um this was self-defense
and do you think this will lead to the
defendant testifying
i mean thematically it's masterful when
you're dealing with facts like these
it's the only route with which you can
go as a competent defense attorney so to
come out tell the story set the theme
right let the jury be thinking all the
way through that this was an act of
self-defense and put it on the
prosecution from the inception to prove
otherwise you know these cases when
we've seen them brian they are
notoriously difficult for the
prosecution to prove to the extent
there's been any domestic violence so
it's going to be an uphill battle i
believe for the prosecution and i would
certainly say great opening from the
defense yeah best uh defense is
sometimes a great offense and they
actually said she will testify so we'll
see how that plays out when we come back
two long island nurses are arrested for
selling fake coven 19 vaccination cards
how the million dollar skiing was
brought to an end and what charges the
women now face
welcome back to law and crime daily two
new york nurses now face charges for
creating fake coven 19 vaccine cards and
collecting 1.5 million dollars in the
process in a very short time
julie
de vuno and marissa uraro are charged
with second second-degree forgery
stemming from their fake vaccine card
scheme
to volrow and also faces charges of
second-degree second-degree charge sorry
offering a false instrument for filing
prosecutors say the two long island
nurses allegedly forged the vaccination
cards and entered the false shots into
the state's immunization database they
were found out only after they allegedly
forged the official card and never gave
a shot to an undercover detective
duvono and ouro charge 220 dollars for
adults but kids got a discount at 85
dollars for the fake cards law
enforcement say they found 900 thousand
dollars in cash during a search of
duvall's
home this prompted internal probe into
her husband who's a new york city police
officer investigators also found a
ledger documenting their profits it
showed the woman had racked in over one
and a half million dollars over just
three months both women have pled not
guilty to all charges
philip how serious are these charges and
are these nurses looking at a lot of
jail time
i mean they're looking at anywhere from
one to three years of course they're
probation eligible with respect to the
charge of a d felony um that they are
facing for this but in terms of the risk
of exposure of course this is very
serious and we know politically this is
a hot button issue so to the extent that
they're going to be moving forward even
with this being on long island as
opposed to directly in the city where
there have been some let's just say
contrast with respect to vaccination and
non-vaccination they still nevertheless
are very much so facing serious charges
and you have one of the nurses whose
husband is a police officer that may be
caught up in this a lot of money lost
we'll see ultimately what happens
absolutely terry according to the police
as we said earlier there was a ledger of
these fake vaccination cards does that
mean that those who they sold these
cards to could be charged as well
absolutely if you are purchasing a fake
vaccination card and you know that it's
fake under new york law you can be
penalized and prosecuted so basically if
a person possesses a forged instrument
you know it's forged you're intending to
deceive that is a crime of fraud and for
that you will be prosecuted and you will
possibly get a fine and you will
possibly get jail time and like phillips
said this is a very political issue and
i think that if they are caught they
will be prosecuted even though there are
so many of them and the amounts are very
small
yeah it's interesting once we start
digging into that ledger and see what
names and who actually pops up well
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you